So, the first thing we need to know about the Nervous System is that it's
divided into two main parts. We have the Central Nervous System, also known as
the CNS for short. And we have the Peripheral Nervous System, or PNS for short.
The Central Nervous System is comprised of the brain and the spinal cord. And
the Peripheral Nervous System is comprised of the nerve cells in the body that
are outside of the central nervous system. Here, let's take closer look at the
Peripheral Nervous System. It's further divided into the Somatic Nervous
System. And this is responsible for transmitting sensory information, such as
sight, smell or even touch to the brain and the spinal cord. Or from the brain
and the spinal cord to the skeletal muscles. The second half of the Peripheral
Nervous System is the autonomic nervous system, as we see here. This system is
in charge of our involuntary systems. Such as our internal organs, like our
heart or lungs. Or the glands, like our adrenal gland.